yeah thank you
I didn't prepare speech like really yeah
just some names I really want to thank
first of all I thank all the people who
made this happen with their money so
it's like the the mi7 who sponsored it
from vienna of the film academy vienna
thanks a lot gap ad film german films
all the cultural forums all around the
world who let us travel around the world
thank you very much
i really want to thank my team they as
some are here tonight thanks all of you
sebastian and Hugh and Anna really and
all the all the other team members I
want to thank the head of University and
Karan - and like all the university
people who like really helped us making
this film and yes and last I want to
thank my parents they are sleeping right
now in Germany thanks to them and yeah
and I want to thank last my wonderful
actors I wouldn't like went through all
this the journeys I've been through
without them so they are not here
they're sleeping - in Germany but yeah
thank you thanks and last of all thanks
the Academy to invite us here to have to
gave us this great week gave us all this
great food we had and thanks to Sean and
Hector and all the people who made this
happen
thank you very much